look we're back we are this is a
different day we just didn't miss you
yeah sorry I am a reject from the Anita
star champ from the rejects yeah she's
the new member of the real region I
showed her Avengers Avengers avenging
Deadpool video from Rocco Rocco but I
told her a lot of the sketches they do
tend to be pretty violent and this video
came out called McDonald's family
reunion from Rocco Rocco so I sent her
over a link and did a last one with the
McDonald family so she could be prepared
for this one with epic epic you know
right up my alley
yeah his famous Ronald all characters
rocky they're talented man they are
talented I'm excited to see what
creepiness they have in store for today
which my nipple and white episode tick
and my nipple still kind of hurts right
now yeah feel like Rob Zombie's don't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell is going on oh my god
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh boy Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tomorrow
you
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my god
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay what did you think that was really
uh hey hey oh they did it yeah they did
Justina phone call is not from the video
yeah what some 805 members calling me
dick all these [ __ ] is the callin
[ __ ] be Omanis all night man fans
just like the kinky all want that
glittery album phone well boy that's all
I thought it was just the right amount
of gore just the right amount yeah I
wonder how they really sit down and
think about this is like it's just like
a lot of them just like really just plan
it out together or do you think this one
guy's like okay this is what's going to
happen to them I imagine they all have
like these little cards okay
is there write down ideas on and then
put them on a wall what we're doing to
put them in this order I think what it
works having finger his dead sister
then pissed on the grandma go to the
hospital kill people that Alan it just
wouldn't be rack of record without it so
you know it was me that [ __ ] hey Emmy
that's how they did down it's surprising
on not their most disturbing video I
think really yeah I've seen some other
visitors are just like flat out like
this isn't even funny it's just so justr
really I will be binge watching them
because it will make these kinds of
videos so interesting is that they're
they're like horror thriller videos yeah
I like I think no this has happened and
then we're just talking like we're gonna
be funny if there was a raw McDonald
movie about their family and it was kind
of like a horror movie that sounds
really fun
that's you in it yeah then they were
executed as a horror so you kind of
forget about the joke and you're just
like this is just really disturbing yeah
yeah yeah yeah there is there's a lot
there's so many different elements of
[ __ ] up but it's hard to like really
pinpoint like you can't do
all that was not know it's like all of
it yeah [ __ ] you know you kind of
forget about the initial joke of it all
baby's getting die just like salivated
towards the camera you probably saw that
I probably work with me yeah you like
that
good all right so yeah there's like this
the baby is getting mistreated there's
lots of insects
there's just the elements of gored
children being murdered and second jump
[ __ ] joke shooting children masturbation
and stuff it's just a lot so much it is
a lot coming at you they delivered
breaking every week because in the first
one they said I'm a Burger King yeah
that was really and now we're gonna take
all one win I'm interested to see
they're down one day I'm excited about
that that's gonna be waiting just make
it already
I really want to be in a Rocco Rocco
video can you call us we'll put on I
wouldn't mind it if they didn't did all
those thing that's in me like it's just
the rack of Ragnar would be I really
want to be in a rack of record video
notes are pissing I'm eating [ __ ] on
my face [ __ ] and then they you know
they you know me and they said they
asked me from behind can't say the word
[ __ ] me for some reasons me like we just
did nah well maybe I can say this dish
then they asked me from a hockey they
[ __ ] you from behind yeah hey it's dry
but I wanted even it bad want the rack
or racquet team to [ __ ] me from boss
[ __ ] him from behind I don't know where
it is Anita just brings us out I bring
it out of him spring/summer Brian writes
recreated a very okay I my vault I'm a
dirty vulgar [ __ ] I'm a dirty
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] rat it had
some Jesus jokes in there it had some
Jesus jokes that was they are out to
offend on everyone there is nominative
just offending and I love it I need to
know because you know if you're gonna if
you're gonna offend just go for it all
you know [ __ ] go full force just
everyone cuz then no one can say
anything I can't watch on how much
racket racket though I could I can't
like be I can pinch I once saw like four
videos from my own back in the back and
I would like
a little bit headache now really yeah
too chaotic it's funny so it's always
funny like I always wanted one after
four in a road like I got hey really
yeah it's good violent and crazy that is
bad
violent and crazy bad not no no really
no I wish I could do all these things
every we should I think that the rejects
should you know Frank channel no they
have to vote on Gregory doing more of
this kind of video because why not like
every other sketch sketch real wait them
again Rio I be down for okay now I don't
why they can kind of run can be real too
much work I'd rather just watch other
people's no I think you could do it
we're talking about you know I you know
I have two sketches in the works right
now yes you do keep a lookout for those
we're planning a vowel sound Amen yeah
we're probably get ready for that
there's so many teasers because Annie
and I are of course in a serious
monogamous relationship waiting we are
brighter register this is a Lannister
racket racket situation laminator record
I'm not why not because we are one it's
we are same person sometimes just him
with you boo nothing sexier than family
Game of Thrones will teach you that mmm
and the elbow would I speak for all the
elbows you're good a channel you can
subscribe today subscribe I need a star
subscribe to her channel girl rejects
subscribe doesn't get seen money [ __ ] on
her Channel I mean eyes got to be a my
channel screen here is supposed to
appear something right here and she is
not Irish like a lot of using not IRA
not an Irish you like a lot of your why
[ __ ] is 100 area with are you my lace I
am NOT representing 50 not even cystic
20 maybe five I can be whatever you want
whatever so that's what I tell everyone
you know whatever they are five hundred
dollars for an hour and it went down to
200 the economy is rough right now row
200 is my going really good you know
bang for your
correct literacy